はい ではよろしくお願いします
今日のテーマはまあ随分何回何回も喋ってる内容で
まあつまらなくなる可能性は十分ありますので
まあ忘年会やる時期でもありますからね
10%ぐらい起きて聞いているければ大丈夫だと思います
で あの まあ心はすべて支配する
決めるということで まああの
順番に進んでいきます
絶対的支配者といういい加減なタイトルなんですけど
まあ我々は誰かに徹底的に支配されて管理しているのかということで
で それにまあ そのものは何だと
まあ自分以外 他者に 誰かに
自分以外 何かに私たちを管理されているのかと
まあわかりやすいんですよ
私が私のことを全部やっているのか
あるいは私以外誰かにやられているのかっていうね
やらされているのかっていうね
で これはまあいろいろ具体的なこと
神様ですかと 神様に全部管理されているのかどうか
あるいはもう神様ではなくて
これただの自然法則で
自然によって我々は管理されているのかと
あるいはいえ そんなことなくて偶然やと
例えば我々の運命とか将来とか
もう何でもかんでもこんなのは偶然だとというふうな
まあいろいろ考えられます
しかし 答えは誰もわからないんですよ
例えば子供が生まれたんですけど
障害を持って生まれたんだと
それは誰かが障害をさせたか
偶然かどうかね わからないんですよ
ただ 自然だと言ったってもね
なんで一人の子供がすごい健康で生まれて
一人が障害弱く生まれるかとかね
だからわからない 誰にも
次に出てくる問題は では自分自身ですかと
自分の全部運命を作ったりするのは
障害になって生まれたのは自分のことでしょうかというと
これもなんかどうかな
そうじゃないでしょという気分になるんです
自分ではなんか喜んで
じゃあ障害者になってやるぞということはありえないでしょうに
じゃあ私は自分の運命を決めて
頭の悪い人間になるぞとかね
それってありえないんですよ
だから自分自身といたっても
なかなかわからないんですよ
それで ではブッダの答えは何なのかと
全ての現象は因縁により生じ
因縁により滅するということで
ブッダの答えはどちらでもないんです
それぞれの現象にそれぞれの原因があるんだよと
だからもう包括的にまとめて
トータル的にこれだというふうな一因一因論は語れません
前にリストにあったのはすべて一因論なんですよ
たった一つの原因ですべて解決するぞという
あの愚かな思考なんですよ
だってそんなの自然の流れやと言ったっても
一円になっちゃうんですね
神様は全部決めたんだよと言ったら
それまた一円論なんですよ
そんな簡単なはずじゃないんです
世の中は 何でも一つの原因だよと言えば
結果も一つになるはずでしょうし
だから一円論じゃないんですね
ブッダへのそれぞれの現象に
それぞれの 因果関係 原因関係があるんだよと
それで因縁によって現れて
因縁によってなくなるんだと
したがって 絶対的な唯一と言える何かは存在しないことになる
ですから 一円論はそれだけでもうアウト
仏教は認めません たった一つの原因で全部なるということはないんです
その時その場での原因関係で
今の現象のあり方を理解できるんです
だから その時その場というね
この時空関係ですね まあそれによって我々の今の現象のあり方というのは理解できるんです
理解しようとするならば
まあ例えばこのプロジェクターは結構光がありますよ
あの かなり映してもらえるぐらいの力は
で まあそれも調べて買う時は買ったんですからね
しかし問題は だからといってその自分の力を発揮しないんですね
なぜかというと 周りの光でこの自分の光を消しちゃうんですよ
だから このプロジェクターの薄りは
その場でその場で変わるんです
ただ 会社でまあこれぐらいのまあ光を出してくれるんだとかね
コントラストはこれぐらいあるんだぞとかね
特にこれは映画を見る観賞用のものじゃなくて
発表に使う文字データ使うためのプロジェクターなんですけど
あれはもう会社の宣伝で
しかし 実際やってみると
なかなかそうはうまくいかないんですよ
だから その時その場でその現象が出てくるんです
色にしたっても同じことで
私はこんな色で作ったはずがないんですけど
かなりすごい綺麗な落ち着いてる色でしたけど
どのこのプロジェクターはもうあまり三原色を丁寧にまとめません
全く自分のモニターで見る色とものすごい違う
信じられないほど だからもうその場でその場で
もっとあのもう 50 万
40 万ぐらいかかるプロジェクターだったら
もしかすると もしかすると色を出してくれる可能性はあります
だからまあ 大体一円で全て処理するんじゃなくて
その時とその場の原因関係で現象結果はどうなっているのかということはわかるんです
だから たとえ障害でもって生まれたんだからといって
じゃああんた障害者だから一生それでいけということはないんです
障害者かないかと その時その場で
その時その場でもう変えて変えていくんですよ
たとえあることに障害があっても
あることには全く障害者でないかもしれません
例えば歩けない そんな子供は車椅子になる
しかし 学校で勉強する場合は
歩けないということは障害にならんでしょうに
車に車椅子に乗るっていうことは障害にならんでしょうに
教室の中では障害者ではありません
だから障害者っていうことも
その時その場なんですよ
そこで子どもたちはもうあのグラウンドで走っている
その子は走れません その場では障害者なんです
だから一ついっぺんに決めることはできません
そういうふうに 我々にとっても
いつでも その時その場で何やということは理解できれば
ものすごく頭が良くなるし
人生も良くなるしね かなり立派な人間にはなります
それで我々はそうじゃないんですよね
障害者と決めつけたら
もう一生障害者で 何か人に何かアイデンティティをつけてしまっちゃえば
もうイメージ作ってしまえば
それに一貫してそれだけでやろうとする
例えば笑い芸人さんたち
が 司会するいろんなところにでも随分真剣
真面目に困った顔をしているとびっくりするんですよ
なんであの人はあんな風にいるんでしょうかと
24時間もゲラゲラゲラアホなことを言って笑っていると思っているんですね
やっぱりそういう人々もその時その場なんですよ
もう舞台の上に出た途端
もうあんな変なキャラクターになるんであって
ビデオカメラでもあのキュー出た途端キャラクター変わるんであって
それはオフになった途端また普通に戻っちゃうんです
だから人っていうのは
その時その場でもう変わって変わっていくものなんですね
それはよく気をつけて理解してください
それでと言っても 全体的にすべての生命と宇宙をまとめて把握するとどうなるのかと
全体的な法則というものがあります
法則というのは英語でいうとプリンシプルということで
どうにもならんということで
1番目はウトニヤームと呼ぶんです
で これはすごいお釈迦様がこの科学者に頭がもう硬くなっている
もうそういう人々にばっかり話したんじゃないんです
その場合は厳密にもう徹底的に厳しくしゃべるんだけど
ごく一般的に誰にでもわかるようにすごい簡単単純でしゃべる
だからこちらに言ってる真理がすごい尊い真理なんですけど
すごい単純な単語を使うんです
季節の法則と そうすると普通の百姓さんもよくわかりますよ
でしょ 秋がなってくると
まあもう秋に逆らうんじゃなくて
まあそれに自分を合わせるしかないんです
夏になってくると それによって自分を合わせるしかないんです
夏に実るものは夏に実るし
秋に実る植物は秋に実るし
そこで秋に実る植物をとにかく夏でやってやるぞということはやりません
時期に合わせて農業をやるとかね
冬がどうしても寒いし
夏は暑いしとかね そういうことなんですね
それで理解十分です しかし
季節の法則って何なのかというと
この宇宙の回転なんですよ
エネルギーで言えば熱のエネルギーなんです
それっていうのは まあどうにもならん
まあ物理学でよく研究していますよ
物の質量と引力と まあいろいろありまして
熱というすごいエネルギーがありまして
で それで全宇宙がもう回転しているんです
これは誰にもどうすることもできませんよ
そこまで言っちゃうと誰にもわからないんだから
お釈迦様 これは季節の法則というんです
で 物質全般の法則でもあります
ですから 宇宙法則でもありまして
物質のすべての物質の法則でもあります
2番目はビージャニヤーム
種の種の法則なんです
そういう種の法則で言ったら誰にでもわかるでしょう
誰も あのかぼちゃの種をまいて
リンゴを期待しません
かぼちゃの種だと これはツルであることも知っているし
だから成長するならば
ツルに適した適切な環境を作ってあげなくちゃいけないし
食べられるのはかぼちゃであってリンゴでないということもはっきり知っています
だから種にある法則が入っていますよ
どんな色の花咲くか どんなものを実るかとかね
どんな形になるのかとかね
葉っぱの形はどうなるのかとかね
実るのは春か秋か 夏かどちらかとかね
これ種の法則になります
種の法則はすごい一般的でわかりやすい
しかし これははっきり言えば遺伝の法則なんです
それ言ったら誰にもわかりませんだからね
いまだに遺伝のからくりを全部わかっているわけでもないでしょうに
それも物質の法則なんですよ
だから宇宙も太陽も地球も物質なんですけど
地球も その物質の中でもある遺伝の法則という
何かあるパターンがあって
そのパターンでも変化していくんですね
植物と生命の中ではそれよく見えます
例えば石があっても 決して石が大きくなったりすることはありません
溶岩が流れてきて 新しいもう溶岩とかもう石とか出てくるかもしれませんだけど
でも例えばこちらに一つの石 1個あると思ったら
それはそのままで まあ減るかもしれませんだけど
増えるってことはありえないんですよ
それは普通の物質の法則なんですよ
でも 10キロぐらい 赤ちゃんって何？どれぐらい重いですか？生まれると 1キロ
2キロ 大体 3キロぐらいね
それでまあ 3キロぐらいの肉体の塊が生まれてるんだけど
これ何年経ってみると
10キロになったら 15 キロになって 20 になったりとかね
同じもの増えてるんですよ
同じ肉 細胞 ほとんど似ている骨の細胞
全く同じもの増えてるんです
別人にはなりません それってすごい不思議ですよ
不思議ということでもないんだけど
もう子供は鶏食べようが
豚肉食べようが キャベツ食べようが関係なく
まあ自分小さい時持って生まれたその同じ細胞をまあどんどんどんどん増やしていくんです
それは植物生命に見える現象で
それはお釈迦様が種の法則ということでまとめています
だからこれ遺伝 遺伝子の法則なんですよ
3番目 チッタニアム それは心の法則
これがすごい これはものすごい難しい
で 心というものがあるんだと
ものではなくで働きがある
特に生命に まあ心っていうことはこれからずっと説明に入りますけど
まあ認識することなんですよ
だから私はこの部屋を認識するんだけど
部屋は私を認識してくれません
だからこの部屋は生き物じゃないんです
私にこのペットボトルを認識することはできるんだけど
ペットボトルは全然私の存在を認識してくれません
だから私は生き物で ペットボトルは生き物でないということになります
それで認識するという働きがありまして
これでかなり物事は変わっていくんです
自分自身も周りも環境も
環境 周りの環境も だから認識するそのもの
心そのものも法則なんです
どうにもない これが生命に見えるもので
生命 命としての法則なんです
命とは何なのかと 生命とは何なのかというと
心ということになるんですね
それでまたもう一つ法則がありまして
今日は説明はいたしませんけど
カンマニアム業の法則
これも心に関わる法則なんですよ
心は認識するんだけど
認識する方向というか道とか
そのやり方 なんかどこかで自由自在にはできないんですね
どこかで何か なんかエネルギーの流れをね
方向を展開させているんですよ
それが業というエネルギー
それも心の中にあるものなんですね
これが生命の差異について法則なんです
だから心で認識するものだったら
みんな平等でなければあかんでしょうに
生命っていうのは心ですよと
言うならば みんなに心あるんだからみんな平等でしょ？でも平等じゃないんです
人間も一人一人違う 人間の動物は違う
動物も一匹一匹違う 同一のものはないんですよ
一卵性双生児の子供でも人であっても違うんですよ
別々な人間なんです これって何やと
なんで生命なのに生命の間で差があるんでしょうかと
なんで統一平等でないのかというと
またあるエネルギーがあるんだよと
それが業ということなんです
カンマですね これでたったこの単純 4つで
人類のすべての疑問にお釈迦様は答え出しています
神様はいるかいないかどうかね
そういうくだらないくだらない妄想ばっかしに陥って
一向に答えが出てこない
で こういう法則であると
これには超越した智慧がなくても
大体智慧があれば理解できるんです
これしかないんだと 宇宙の中で
わかるはずなんです だから
この 4つをすごい大事なポイントなんです
宇宙と生命に対して理解しようと思えば
こんな明確にはどこでも誰でも語られてはないんです
次に 四大法則がわかったということで
この相互関係 互いに関係を持って変化していくんです
四大法則は独立して機能するのではない
法則だからどこにあるかっていうことじゃないんですよ
法則っていうのはある働きの説明だから
これ明らかに法則っていうのは頭だけの発見なんです
これ 科学の世界でも同じですよ
いろいろ公式やらね いろんなもう方程式
法則などなど発見する
これはまあ頭の働きなんですけど
この法則は法則はどこにあるのかと下がったってもね
どこにでもあります それで法則自体が独立して活動するわけじゃないんです
相互依存して機能するんですね
お互いに 例えば生命 心っていうのは知ることでしょうに
だから知ることっていうのは何？何を知るのかっていうことでしょ
だから何を知るのかと
知るものによって知るっていうことが変わっていくんですよ
花を知るか ご飯を知るかっていうことなんでしょうに
花を知った時の知識とご飯を知った時の知識はそれぞれ違うんですね
だから知る機能も他のものによって変化する
業さえも同じなんですよ
まあ業っていうのは このお互い人の差を作る働きなんですけど
でも環境はあんまりも変わっていくと
この差がなくなったりもします
例えば あんまり勉強には興味がない業の人が生まれる
そのまま放っておけば何も勉強しないで人生終わりますけど
周りは全然放っておけない
あらゆる工夫して 強引に無理やりに脅したりまでして
もう勉強させたりしちゃうと
結局は勉強する羽目になっちゃうんです
だから普段他の子供よりは苦しいかもしれませんだけど
業が自分の機能はできなくなったんですよ
だからこの 4つの法則っていうのは
互いに関係を持って依存して機能するんですね
例えば 種遺伝の法則は理解しやすいように見えますが
必ずしも予測できる結果を出すとは限らないんですよ
この法則の中で 我々に一番理解しやすいのは遺伝の法則なんですよ
この 4つの法則の中で
まあ科学ではまだまだ全部研究終わってないんだけど
一番単純簡単です 4つの法則の中で
遺伝子の法則といっても
リンゴの種を見てわかりますかね？どんな木になるか
どんな色のリンゴになるかとかね
これがわからない あるいは強引に変えることさえもできる
言語は気にはなるんだけど
実らないようにすることもできる
だから生まれた子供がもう人間の子供だから
親の遺伝を持っているんだから
まあこんな風に大人になるでしょうというふうな
もう一般大雑把な推測ができるんだけど
だからといってそうなるんでしょうかね
なぜならば その遺伝が周り環境によって自分の結果出しながら成長するか変化していくんですよ
だから種というのは遺伝ということだから
種はずっと周りの法則に従って自分の回転しなくちゃいけないんです
それでこの相互関係わかると思います
心にも自分の法則はあるが
そちらの流れも自然 種と業の法則によって変わることがある
それで心の場合も 我々の心の場合も
自分で自分の法則を持ってますけど
そう簡単に法則の通りにというか
もう決まっているパターンではいかないんです
別な原因によっていろいろ変わったりはします
うん まあ例えば仏教の瞑想修行にしたっても
どんな人でも修行すれば悟られるということは基本的な考え方なんですけど
これが肉体のせいでできない人々もいるんですよ
遺伝的に 例えばもう体がものすごくでっかくて
もう管理不可能で もう言うことを聞かないわとかね
座ってはいられないわとか
歩くことしたって もうすごい疲れるわとか
食いしん坊でいくら食っても食っても足らんわとかね
そういうものになってくると
心には機能できなくなっちゃうんです
そこで遺伝のせいでダメになる場合もあります
それから因縁と法則って何やと
違うものですか？と 仏教は因縁だからね
違うものではありません
様々な因縁の流れを全般的に観察すると
この 4つの流れになるだけ
だから あらゆる因縁 いろんなものは変化していくんですよ
因縁によって それを見たら
まあ 4つの法則があるんだぞということは言えるんですね
だから違うものではないんです
因縁の流れは 4つに分かれているだけ
因果を知ると 果を適切に変えることができますが
それは法則という枠の中で行わなくてはならない
例えば 因と果を果を知っているならば
自分好きな果を出すために因変えればいいんですよ
でもそう簡単じゃないんです
この法則の中で変えなくちゃいけないんですね
電車で来るよりは飛んできた方が早いんですよ
短距離で飛べますけどね
まあそれはわかるんだけど
飛べないんですよ 飛びたければ
その法則の中で何とかしなくちゃいけない
飛行機に乗るとか 飛行機に乗れる
乗るためにはもう成田か羽田まで行かなくちゃいけないし
羽田に行ったんですけど
茅ヶ崎回館ではもう降りられないし
いろいろ問題は出てくるんですね
だからそううまくはいかないんですね
だからもう生きる世界っていうのはそう心配じゃないんです
だから あなた勉強すれば頭が良くなるに決まってるでしょうと
それからまあ勉強すればうまくいきます
いい加減なことを言っても
もうそのなんて言いますか
あらゆる法則の中でどうやって原因を変えるのかっていうことは大事なんです
人の好き勝手に 希望通りに現象は変えないんですね
だから好き勝手ではなくて
法則に従って変えてくださいという話なんです
だから法則を教えてあげるんです
今日から私は怒りませんよと言ったっても怒るんですよ
そう簡単じゃないんです
では明日悟ってやるぞと
そんなできるものじゃないんです
そんなにいいものだったら
では悟りますと はい 悟ったと
もう麻原彰晃じゃないんだからね
では無知な人を騙すためにはいいんだけど
だから明日から怒りませんよと言ったってもね
法則がありますから 法則によって怒らないような心を作らなくちゃいけないんです
因果法則を知ると 好ましくない果を変えられますが
法則という枠の中で行わなくてはならない
それはもう分かりましたね
例えば十二因縁ありますね
仏教で 全部書いてないんですけど
皆様まあ私より明確に覚えているんだから
一応 無明から行が生じて
行から識が生じるとかね
それで これで一切の苦しみが生まれるんだという十二因縁がありますね
で すべての苦 それからすべての苦
まあこのように まあちょっと読むと難しくなりますけど
この因果の流れがあります
エオメータスケーバラスドッカカンダサムディホーティ
このようにすべての苦しみの現れであると
無明から始めて それでお釈迦様は言うんですよ
アヴィッジャヤッテーワ
アセーサヴィラーカニローダ
無明というこのものがなくしちゃえば
まあ行も無くし 色も無くし
受ももう何でもかんでもなくなって
最後に一切の苦しみもなくなりますよと
この逆順で因果法則を語る場合はえらい簡単です
無明のせいで全ての苦しみが生まれるんだったら
では無明を消しちゃえば？答えは簡単です
でも実際はそう簡単じゃないんです
無明をなくせば全ての苦もなくなりますが
無明を断つのは法則に従って修行ということで行うんですよ
だからみんな頑張ってますよ
あらゆる修行 戒律を守るは
いろんなことをしてして仏教も学ぶはもう大変ですよ
それって法則なんです
そういう法則に従って無明を断たなくちゃいけない
ただ もう自分が じゃあ私は無明なくなりましたと発表しただけで
無明なくなったわけにはなりません
で それでその話は終わって
次にはこの生命と宇宙って何やっていうことで
仏教では宇宙の観察には興味ありません
もうみんな知ってるでしょう
生命の苦しみをなくすために役に立たないからです
宇宙はどれぐらい大きいかとかわかっても
ブラックホールのことをわかっても
ビッグバンのことをわかっても
あらゆる星団のことをわかっても
何の役にも立ちません
人間の苦しみには だから仏教には興味ないんです
生命には 4つの法則も
生命には 4つの法則は当てはめます
それで あの 4つの法則は宇宙の法則でもありますけど 4
つの法則を使って仏教では宇宙論を語ってないんです
だから生命だけ 命のことだけ
一切の生命について法則を当てはめて語っているんです
物質に対しては自然法則と種の法則という 2つです
それで宇宙のことを理解したければ
自然法則と種の法則を研究すればよくわかります
自然法則というのは物理学でしょうし
科学者はそれをやっているし
種の法則はまあ生物学者はやっているし
そんなに分かりたければ
でもその2つわかっても
生命は何やと科学者にはわかりません
科学では心の法則 業の法則はもうまだ発見してないんです
心の法則と法則と業の法則は生命を司るんですよ
そこで生命体を管理するのは心の法則と業の法則なんです
だから この最後のところだけは仏教の管轄なんですね
時々もう必要に応じてこちらにも引用するんで
例えば宇宙はもう無限にたくさんの星があるんだぞとかね
もうキリがないんだよと
いくら調べても調べてもまたあるんだよと
というふうにちょこちょこっと言うだけで
時間的にはもうもう気が狂うほど長いんだよとかね
当時でインドで発見しなかったものはもう淡々とお釈迦様は言ってますけど
それは自分がすごい知ってるんだぞというふうに言うためではなかったんです
そういうお釈迦様を宇宙について語られたものは
今 最近になって科学の発見によってはなるほど当たってるなとわかるだけのことで
最近までもみんなただブッダの言葉だから信じただけで
あまりわからなかったんです
だからこの必要に応じて
こういうところにお釈迦様は引用するんだけど
メインテーマではありません
仏教のテーマはこれなんですね
最後に 生命の体を自然と種の法則が管理する
それで心の法則とこの生命を司る
また 生命といっても肉体がありますね
肉体は物体ですよ この肉体は自然法則と種の法則なんです
だから肉体のことを知ってるんだからといって
生命のことを全部知っているわけじゃないんです
医者は体のことを細胞まで知り尽くしても
人間として命としてのものを知りません
細胞一個一個まで 脳細胞のこともまででも何でも知り尽くしたっても
でも何か違いますよ 生き物としては
ということはあるんです
で 次に行きます それでセクション 1つ終わりました
知る機能によって生命という
生命って何でしょうかというと
仏教は科学的な定義で知る機能ですと知る機能あれば生命です
すっごく単純で簡単です
で じゃあ中身に入ってみます
これはタイトルで 心の発見
知る機能っていうのは心ですから
自分はこれから心の発見してみましょう
かなり具体的に 死体と自分を比較して何が違いますかと発見してくださいと
それは心の発見する一番簡単な方法なんです
死体と自分を比べる 比べて何が違いますかと
で みんなすごく頭が良いな
すごく頭が良さそうなんです
私はこの質問は毎回毎回瞑想すると出しますけど
なかなか誰もわからないんですよ
死体と自分が何が違いますかと
ある方がもう魂がないんだよと
あれ 何言ってるの あんたはと
私は驚きましたけど あんた見たことあるの？と
魂はと 見たこと触ったことあるのかと
そしたらすごく怒られたんです
馬鹿にされたと すごい頭良かったんですね
本人は 死体と自分の差は魂がないことで
冗談 もう本当にもう何回も
このこれを瞑想する時はとても大事なことで
で これは瞑想はすっごくスピードアップするために
もう何年も修行で体験しなくちゃいけないことは
私はまあできるだけ 10 分で 15 分で
もうすっともう超特急で押してやろうと思って出す質問なんですけど
一応推測して まあそれなりに常識的な知識があるだろうと
まあびっくりんこするだけで
私も 死体は家 机 木 土などと全く同じ物体です
死体っていうのは この間
木曜日の瞑想会で物体でしょと言ったら
ある女の子が え？親しい人の死体はそんな物体じゃないんだと
もう気持ち悪いものでも何でもないんだと
ああそう でもあなたの親しい人のいた死体はね
私にとっては物体で大嫌いやと
そうじゃないんでしょうかって
それはそうでしょうと
だから親しいかどうかって関係なく
死体は物体なんです それは母の死体だからとかね
そんな関係ないんです
死体は物体です これは家と机と木と
もうもう壁と全然変わりはないんです
しかし 生きている私は単純に物体だとするのは難しい
私も単純な物体だよと
死体も単純な物体だよというのは
これができないんですよ
私は生きているんだから
そういうわけで具体的に発見しています
で これからは皆様すごく損します
瞑想する人々には初めての質問として出しますから
その時は頭が回転して無明が破れて
分別する知識が生まれますけど
一旦行っちゃうとこれがカットになるんです
よく覚えてください もうよく
私と死体 私は働く 動く
心臓が動く 働く 呼吸している
栄養を取る 体温がある
怪我したら治る まあ朽ちることはない
死体になってくると動きません
心臓は止まっている 呼吸しない
栄養は取らない 栄養を取らない
冷たい 再生しない 腐っていく
バカバカらしく聞こえる
見られる 感じるでしょうね
とんでもないことです
これが本当の知恵の世界なんです
本当の科学的に見ると
これなんです 魂がないとか霊魂がないとかね
いい加減なことじゃなくて
そこで一人一人すごく不思議なんでしょうね
例えば 1番目 私はもう動くでしょうに
これが生きてるっていう証拠でしょう
アメーバを顕微鏡で見たってのは
アメーバが生きているかないかっていうことは
どうやって知るんですかね
顕微鏡の中で あれ 水の中で動いてるんだったら生きてるんです
全く動かなかったらもうわからない
だから細胞 1個 1個いつでも動いてますよ
だからそれがすごい不思議なことなんです
この動きって何なのかと
それで心臓が まあ私たちには心臓もありますからね
心臓が働いているでしょうね
これにしても すべて物理学法則を壊しているでしょうに
これぐらい長い血管に
もう生まれた時からお腹の中から始めて
死ぬまで絶えず血液をポンプするという機械なんかは作れませんよ
機械作ってもまたまた修理したり点検したり
部品入れ替えたり いろいろしなくちゃいけない
これがなくよく もう人間には作れないほど強烈なポンプなんですよ
でも心臓ってただの肉の塊
こんな力あるのかと これにはと
ちょっと駅まで走っただけでもうもう息切れるのに
息が切れるのに だからそれってのはすごいことで
これが生きているということなんです
で 呼吸しているっていうことも
ずっとこの酸素を入れたり
入れて入れて入れて入れていくんですね
で 栄養をとる 栄養をとるっていうことはまた不思議なことで
細胞一個一個 24時間瞬間も止まることなく栄養をとっているんです
もう口で食べることだけじゃないんです
栄養をとるっていうことは
我々は 24時間食べなくちゃいけないんです
だから栄養をとるっていうことは
口で食べることだけではなくて
ずっと細胞にずっと栄養が入っているんです
で これ そういうすごい信じられない機能
細胞には栄養がなくなった途端死んじゃう
だからすごいことですよ
そこで体温もすごいことでしょう
ずっと一定の温度で体の中で熱を作っているんですよ
だから走ったりすると体は暖かくなるんですけど
何もしないでいても ちゃんと体の中でエネルギーは燃えて燃えて
一定の温度で保っているんです
そこで法則の中で この自然の法則と種の法則がありますから
周りが寒くなってくると
もう体がもう一定の温度で保つのは大変だから
いろいろなんとかそれなりに合わせて工夫したりする
そこで死体なんかはもう 35度でずっと1日
あるいは 1週間ぐらい保っておこうというと
結構大変な機械が必要になるんですよ
すごくエネルギーがかかりますよ
お金がかかりますよ 例えば死体を温めておこうと思って
何か暖かい箱に入れても
周りは暖かくなるんですけど
中はどうでしょうかね
中まで熱は通りません
そこで中の細胞まで熱が通ろうとしちゃうと
外の方がすごくものすごく熱くなっちゃうんです
これってできることじゃないんです
これ自体摩訶不思議でしょうに
我々はそうじゃなくて
もう中も外も全部同じ
それから怪我したら治るということ
これ再生のことなんですけど
自然のものっていうのは
自分で自分を治すっていうことは誰もしませんよ
生命だけ それするのは
自分で自分を治す 処理する
なんで人間そういうことを発見しないんですかね
命ってな 死体と自分が何が違いますかというと
いくらでもあるでしょう
また そういうものは徹底的に研究する必要もないでしょうに
当たり前の事実 この当たり前のことは真剣に考えないんだから
無知になっちゃうんです
物体なんか壊しちゃったら壊したで壊れたで
物体なんかは自然にだいたい壊れて壊れて壊れていくプロセスですよ
生まれて生まれていくということはないんです
地球にしたっても どんどんどんどん壊れていく
太陽にしたっても どんどんどんどん壊れていく
山も川も何でもかんでも壊れていくんです
成長していくということはないんです
壊れて別な形になるだけ
だから ある一方的一方方向で生きてるんですよ
生命は違うんですね 我々のは
人間から見れば 人間はもう 25代後までは年まではどんどんどんどん成長して増やしていって
それからあるもう 10年
15年  20ぐらい一定の状態でいて
それから減っていくんですよ
それでも修復機能はいつでも持っている
怪我したらたちまち細胞がそれ直しちゃうんです
だからこのそれ再生するということをね
大変なことなんですよ
それからまあ だからこそいつも朽ちらないんですね
まあ腐るんだけど 腐ったものを捨てちゃって新しいものを作ったといって
我々の体っていうのは肉体でしょうね
こんな 35度でいるならば
みるみるうちに腐るはずなんですよ
皆様が買っている肉なんかはずっと冷凍庫でしょ？スーパーに売ってるあの死んでる肉体は
その肉体を買おうといっていく肉体が腐らないんですね
冷凍庫ではなくて暖房をつけているんですよ
買ってきた肉も暖房ついてる部屋に置いておいてください
すぐ腐るんです だから自然法則と違うでしょ
生きている肉体は 自然法則で言えば
こんな暖かい部屋に生肉を置いちゃうと
もう早くも腐って悪臭を出すんですよ
でも我々の肉体はそうじゃないんです
ちょうど腐る年度ですよ
温度ですよ  35 から 40の間っていうのは
どんな肉でもたちまち腐ってしまうね
温度です   80 とか 110 とかね
150 200 になってくると
まあ干し肉になりますけど
でも体っていうのはこの
大変ですよ こういうところはよくリストをよく覚えてください
一つ一つものすごい不思議なものなんです
生きているということは
それから私は話す 蹴られたら痛い
反応するんでしょ？見える
聞こえる 味わう 触覚がある
体で感じる 遺体は話さない
転ぶだけで反応しない
遺体蹴っても転ぶかもしれませんだけど
何の反応もないんですね
自分たちを蹴ったら 誰かがただでは済みませんね
それで我々には見えるんだけど
遺体の目は反応しない
それはちょこっと ここら辺はこの推測というか
実験しないとわからないんですよ
ここまでのものは その 1発でわかる事実です
100%もう確かです
ここから見えるところからは素早く働くんです
それで私には見えることはまあまあ証拠はいらん
しかし 遺体にも目はありますけど
死体にも何を見せても別にどうったことないんですよね
例えばサーチライトみたいに
このスポットライト目に入れたっても全然
そこで自分の目に誰かスポットライトを当てちゃうと
もう痛くて涙が出て もう何も見えなくなっちゃってひどい目にあいますよ
だから遺体はもう何目に何を見せても
蛇を見せても もうすごい格好美しい花を見せても全然反応ないんですよ
だから反応はないということにするしかないんです
耳も同じでしょうね 私たちのはちょこっとあんた何やと言っただけでも腹が立つでしょうね
遺体には言いたい放題悪口言ってみてください
耳元で反応はないんです
だから聞こえないということは推測できる
だから舌も反応しないし
どんな辛いものも遺体に遺体の舌の上に入れてもね
大丈夫です で それで体も何にも触っても無反応ですね
そこで遺体と死体と私の差がまたリストが出てきたんです
この見えるところまで上は全部一発で知ってることで
ここ下は微妙に調べたらよくわかるんです
むちゃくちゃ推測する必要はないんです
まあ大体リストはこんな程度です
また ちょこちょこっと推測できるリストはあります
笑ったり怒ったりする
その他の感情も私にはあります
えーと 眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報について考える
私は目耳鼻から入る情報について考えます
何の音でしょうかとかね
なんか玄関の方に音がして
泥棒でも入ったんでしょうかとかね
と考えたりする 悩んだり
落ち込んだり 妄想したりする
それで今ではなくて 今の状況で満足できず
環境と自分を変えようとする
私たちはずっとそれをやっています
この部屋に入ったら ちょっと寒いんだったら
その状況に満足しないんですね
暖房ないかな 暖房ないかなと
暖房をつけようとするんです
夏は夏 この部屋に来たらやっぱり暑い
何か冷房ないかなとかね
いつでも環境を変えようとしてるんです
これ 生きるものがやっていることで
犬も猫もミミズも誰でもやってます
環境を変えること 満足しない
死体はそうじゃないんです
冷凍したっても死体はへっちゃらで
それで冷凍から出して火葬場に持っていって
もうガスで燃やしちゃうでしょう
全然大丈夫です 大体死体はいっぱいおしゃれさせるでしょうね
死体にとってはどうでもいいんです
押されさせちゃっても
裸にしたっても 我々ですよ
それも我々は環境には満足しない
変えよう変えようとしています
死体は笑ったり怒ったりはしない
わかるのはそれだけなんだよ
死体は笑わない 怒らない
その他の感情もない だろうと推測はできます
だから 笑ったり怒ったりしないんだから
嫉妬したりもしないでしょう
死体は だからそれ推測です
確かな情報じゃない 遺体の心臓は動いてないんだぞというぐらいの確かな情報じゃないんです
微妙な推測なんです で
考えないと推測できます
まあよくみんなね こんな質問出すと
よくみんな先に言うのは
死体は何も考えていないんだぞ
どうやってあんた知ってるのかと
だからもう推測のことを当たり前のことに言うんですよ
それダメなんですよ 死体は考えてるかないか分かるわけないでしょうね
それは推測なんです だって眼耳鼻舌身
反応しないでしょ 情報入らないんですね
私は眼耳鼻舌身に入る情報で考えてるんだから
目に何か入ったらこれは何だろうとかね
美しいものでしょうとかね
で 私は考える 目は反応しないんだったら
そこは不可能になるのは当たり前でしょうに
耳に音が入っちゃうと
私はなんて綺麗な音楽でしょうかとかね
それは誰の歌でしょうかとか考えたりする
死体の目は反応しないんだから
そういう考え方はなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから死体は考えないっていうことは推測であって
それも科学的なちゃんとした推測なの